voici les premières images des indrais
du tristement célèbre navire
d'exploration hms terreur qui a sombré
dans l'arctique canadien autour de 1848
à l'aide de robots télécommandés des
chercheurs de parcs canada ont réussi à
explorer le premier pont du bateau là où
vivaient les marins officiers des objets
du quotidien et tac des verts des
bouteilles des tables tout est conservée
grâce à une fine couche de sédiments et
par le froid glacial n'est qu'en 2016
après des années de recherches que les
scientifiques canadiens ont localisé
l'épave du hms terreur à 25 mètres de
profondeur loin du hms erebus le
deuxième bateau de l'expédition
auparavant on a découvert les restes
d'une vingtaine d 133 membres de
l'équipage morts de faim et dont
certains auraient été victimes de
cannibalisme
mais jamais ceux du responsable de
l'expédition le britannique john
franklin parti à la recherche du fameux
passage du nord ouest
en fait toute l'histoire de ce désastre
navatte a fait l'objet de plusieurs
livres et denis télésérie américaine à
grand déploiement comme en 2d bateaux
les plus modernes de la puissante marine
anglaise se sont ils subitement
transformée en vaisseau fantôme
le ministère pourrait et éclaircies si
on récupère certains documents compense
découvrir derrière cette porte celle de
la cabine du capitaine dans le meilleur
des cas on mettrait la main sur
l'équivalent du saint graal le journal
de bord du hms théorie du bon avec un
peu de chance l'équipe de parcs canada
pourrait ramener plusieurs artefacts en
surface d'ici deux semaines avant
l'arrivée des premiers grands froids ici
normand grondin radio-canada mourir